500 meters beneath these cheshire fields
in 20 salt caverns each large enough to
contain the arc de triomphe lies enough
natural gas to supply britain for a day
this is the largest onshore natural gas
storage facility in the uk just one
percent of the country's annual gas
supply is in storage compared to more
than 20 in france and germany one reason
we've been so exposed to the global
price spike
more storage provides a much better
buffer um so much better buffer from
um
you know cost
in the very short term ultimately the
price is what the market dictates and
therefore it doesn't help in that sense
but immediately
and it also buffers from supply
challenges
so that you know europe is much more
resilient
and less
less dependent on imports
the crisis has claimed two more
suppliers avro and green energy ceasing
trading because they can no longer
afford to deliver cheap tariffs offered
to their 830 000 customers regulator
ofgem says they won't be the last
it's not unusual for suppliers to go out
the market i think what's different this
time is that dramatic change in the
costs that those suppliers are facing we
do expect a large number of customers to
be affected you know we've already seen
you know hundreds of thousands of
customers affected that may well go well
above that but but without sort of
betraying commercial conversations we're
having right now it's very hard for me
to put a figure on it
customers will be moved to other
providers but with wholesale prices
hundreds of pounds higher than the
regulated price cap everyone will move
at a loss the taxpayer may have to
underwrite the consumer experience has
to be as smooth as possible and second
consumers have to be protected from
exorbitant prices we have and and within
that we have to
protect
vulnerable consumers those are the top
priorities
production of co2 is due to restart at
this plant on t side after ministers
agreed to pay the company's energy bills
to prevent shortages affecting food and
medical supplies and even the safety of
nuclear reactors
the gas crisis has exposed the
vulnerability of critical national
infrastructure and industries to even
short-term shocks and it comes with the
economy so reliant on just-in-time
supply of everything from energy to eggs
already disrupted by the pandemic and
brexit
britain hopes one day to end its
reliance on gas for now invisible and
invaluable it's a resource we can't live
without paul kelso sky news in cheshire